He gives zero fucks.
Your Ratha drove,
rode to the Experia and Canada's rough if you get up drunk driving in America,
good luck in Canada.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of um,
a lot of fighters have issues getting into Canada for fights.
A lot of comedians have issues.
A lot of comedians have had issues getting into the Montreal comedy festival,
which is one of the big events for standup comedians because of drunk driving.
Yes.
Cause a drunk driving conviction.
Any domestic violence or anything like that?
Yeah,
Eddie Bravo had um,
an arrest for having a gun on him legally.
Okay.
He was a working for a check cashing place and he used to have to carry large
sums of cash in his car to another location.
And so he would leave with the check cashing company and he had a registered
concealed carry permit for a gun.
And so,
uh,
he got pulled over for something and he had to tell the,
the cop officer I worked for check cashing company,
I have a legal registered handgun in my car right now.
It's loaded.
And then they go,
okay,
hold on a second,
we're going to put you in handcuffs and we're going to run this.
So they run it.
They go,
okay,
checks out.
They let him go because he was not even supposed to be on his record because it
was all legal.
It doesn't matter.
Every time he goes to Canada,
they sit him down.
Tell us about this.
You have a gone on side.
You what?
I now take a gun.
You should to go for the border.
No,
no,
no.
I was,
I was working for a company.
I was allowed to have this kind of like it cut.
He's got an extra hour every time he goes into Canada,
it happened quickly.
And immigration going into Canada.
What'd you get?
What it was your issue?
Well,
they asked me if I'd ever been convicted of a crime and I said no,
and I go sit down and then they call me over and they said,
uh,
the guys,
like you said you'd never been convicted of a crime,
correct?
I said,
yeah.
He said,
is there anything you'd like to say about Fairbanks Alaska in 1983 and I was
like,
uh,
yeah,
I got busted in Fairbank's,
you know,
a for eating a snickers bar and the fucking grocery store and not paying for it.
And,
but I did two or three days.
It was Memorial Day weekend.
I did three,
four nights in the prison.
And then the guy said 20 hours of community service and this will disappear from
your record and get if you don't get arrested in a year.
So I always say no,
cause that's,
yeah,
it wasn't convicted of anything.
And they said it would be taken from my record.
And the guy's like,
nope.
The fact that you were not Alaskan,
so you're from out of state meant they couldn't strike it from your record.
So,
and it's on your FBI record,
which is what we get in Canada.
So he was knicker thief.
Yeah,
I'm a sneaker thief.
So he's a cool guy.
I did four days in a fee in a federal medium security prison with no underwear
for a snickers,
for snickers.
What do you mean with no underwear?
Were you wearing anything or just naked?
I was a wearing short.
Why did you have pants at the groceries?
Because it makes it
more harrowing.
Come on man.
I was,
I was 19 years old.
Not yet will you liked very twink ish.
I was twinkie.
I was very,
yeah.
So you were worried it was all going to go down.
It would have been worried if I were wearing,
you know what a anything survival suit.
But yeah,
it's that even isn't that under the amount of money that they could even bust
you for something?
Maybe not in the 80s Reagan was president.
They were trying to fucking be tough on crime.
Just say no.
Yeah.
And also I had a,
I mean what happened was we got in from this 10 day hitch with these two guys I
had met on the ferry coming up the inside passage and we had this long hitch
through the Yukon territory,
all this crazy shit.
And,
and we get to Fairbank's.
So the first place we go is the laundromat because we stank,
right?
We didn't have that special soap that your defense defense.
So and a,
so we went to the laundromat,
we put everything possible in the washer.
So all three of us were wearing shorts with no underwear,
boots with no socks and a jacket with no shirt.
And then one of the guys was like,
oh,
he wanted to go to the grocery store because there was a payphone.
And he was going to call his girlfriend to let her know that he'd arrived on
time.
And I was like,
fuck it.
I'll go over with you.
And the other guy's going to stay with the bags or backpacks and all that shit.
And you know,
watch the clothes.
So I went with him.
Somebody who's on the phone,
we start pushing a cart around.
We were like,
you know,
Soviet immigrants,
like,
oh,
so many kinds of,
you know,
food here,
because we'd been living in the woods eating nuts and chocolate in LSD for the
last 10 days.
And so he,
he opened a thing of Keifer.
First time I'd ever heard of Keifer,
which is like liquid yogurt and drank that great for your body.
Acidophilus.
And I,
uh,
I,
for some reason,
eight a snickers bar,
even though I'd been eating chocolate and not much imagination there.
And then we,
he used the phone,
we ditch the cart and we laughed.
And so there's some security guy had seen us and turned into a thing.
This cop showed up and I had a knife in my boot and some grass in my pocket,
both of which were legal at the time in Alaska,
but it was enough to make this cop not like me at all.
And he was like this,
you know,
he'd Napoleonic cop kind of situation and he didn't like smart ass college kids
from outside coming into Alaska in the summer and know snickers bar walking
around.
Yeah.
Fucking around with Kiefer.
So he took us,
he handcuffed us and took us to prison.
Fairbank's correctional center.
Did you not have the money for the snickers bar?
Yeah,
we have plenty of money.
He just didn't want to pay for it,
but it was like,
well,
you tell it to the magistrate.
Oh,
you mean for that now that was just like,
I don't know what the fuck you're just young and we're just telling Tom and you
know,
and maybe there was a line or something,
I don't remember,
but we pretended we were shopping so we put like dog food and Shit in the cart,
you know,
and we had our stuff and put the package like we were going to pay for it when
we checked out.
So I don't know what we were just being dumb,
but uh,
yeah,
so we ended up being taken to this prison and I had a pipe to,
cause I remember when we were,
did the intake,
the guy that like the prison dude who booked us and you know,
did the whole intake thing,
I was joking with him,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not going to get that pipe and grasp back.
Am I?
And he was like,
I don't think so man.
I was like,
well,
you know,
it wouldn't bother me if it just disappeared and was never even registered
because grass is hard to come by in Alaska was then.
And so we sort of had a little understanding and like I'm cool,
you're cool.
Cause he was like,
what the fuck you have sneakers bar,
why would this guy,
what's wrong with that cop?
Did you like hit him or something?
And I'm like,
no,
it,
you know,
he just had a hair up his ass.
Right?
So this guy was cool.
He saved us because what he did is he said,
look,
I'm not going to put you guys in with the general population.
You're going to sleep in the gym at night.
You've got some cots,
you sleep in the gym,
you never let the other one out of your sight the whole time you're here,
you go to the bathroom together,
you go to the showers together,
you watch each other's back and you'll get through it all right.
And we did and he was wild.
And this was like 83,
I guess.
And um,
so the,
there's a lot of money in Alaska,
right?
From all the oil.
So the prison was plush.
It was like every meal was all you can eat,
really solid bar,
whole wheat rolls,
white roles.
Wednesday was prime rib day where the cops could pay a buck to eat with the
prisoners.
But the catch was you only had 20 minutes each meal.
So I remember like one day we're sitting there at this table and I wouldn't like
19 maybe 20 maybe 20 something like that.
We're sitting at this table and the guy across the table looked like Charles
Bronson.
You remember him,
the stash and the tats and all that,
and we're just like,
this dude was shoveling it in and he looks up at one point he says,
this is the best fucking prison I've ever been in.
Yikes.
And you know,
laundry lists of prisons that don't,
don't meet that criteria to standard.
Yeah,
he,
his story was,
he founded dude with his wife and he beat him with a lead pipe and he didn't
know if he was dead,
but as soon as it happened,
he got in his car,
he was from like New Mexico or Arizona.
He got in his car and drove to Alaska because he knew he'd get picked up and he
wanted to get picked up in Alaska because he'd heard the prisons were much
better.
That's hilarious.
So he might've beat a guy to death and said,
the way to deal with this is to go to a place that I was awesome.
Prisons and that place just happens to be on the exact opposite.
Yeah.